aie aie aie aie
ayem un emmy en août 2003 j'ai 23 ans je
fais leurs techniciens son et je
travaille pour une très grosse botte de
son qui décident de m'envoyer pendant
quelques jours au nigeria avec une
équipe de lyon pourra l'installer du son
pour les huitièmes jeux d'afrique
il s'agissait d'installer toutes les
cabines de traduction dans le village
officiel des huitièmes jeux d'afrique
d'ailleurs ça c'est mon badge de
l'époque on décolle de lyon lyon
heathrow heathrow abuja nigeria
l'arrivée au nigeria c'est assez
incroyable
en réalité pour ceux qui sont jamais
allés en afrique le nigérien c'est
vraiment un autre monde et à 23 ans je
peux vous assurer que j'ai pris une des
plus grosses claques de ma vie lâche t
on donc à landrin calandre à gt fritsch
et dixon n'a pas le sens de succès il ya
le sang à la base on devait rester
quelques jours à abuja histoire
d'arriver en en 1 2 jours de
s'acclimater d'installer des cabines de
rentrer et de revenir après pour le
démontage sauf que toute la logistique
avait été relativement mal géré ils nous
ont envoyés directement en avion et une
fois qu'on était arrivés sur place
quelques jours après ils ont envoyé tout
notre matériel par container autant dire
par la mer ça a pris énormément de temps
donc au final voulu dresser quelques
jours abuja on est resté un mois un mois
quand vous n'avez pas de matos quand
vous avez rien à faire ce que vous
assurer que les journées sont longues et
que vous avez de quoi vous ennuyer alors
oui je sais pas si tu as déjà été dans
des zones cno et le paludisme
le premier fléau quand tu arrives dans
ces zones là c'est pas le paludisme
c'est les médicaments anti pas lui en ce
qui me concerne ça m'avait complètement
rendue malade j'avais le bilan en vrac
c'était juste insupportable les
habitants de nigeria sont des gens qui
sont extrêmement gentils c'est un pays
qui est très beau extrêmement pauvre on
était logés dans des conditions
extraordinaires un cinq étoiles sheraton
alors cinq étoiles la nigériane vous
avez quand même les câbles qui dépasse
en dessous des cheveux sinon c'est pas
rigolo
on va essayer d'appeler mon driver
directement même je vous demandais au
bonhomme c'est possible
mes hommes
[Musique]
il
elle contient
jean
tout ce qui était assez incroyable par
contre c'était de voir à tous les coins
de rue des militaires armés avec des
armes automatiques des m16 ça foutait
franchement la chair de poule
il y avait un espèce de climat
hypertendus on a sympathisé avec pas mal
de monde mais ils nous ont expliqué
qu'en réalité je n'étais pas du tout il
se sentait pas en sécurité surtout la
nuit il y avait des familles qui
habitaient dans des maisons elles se
rejoignaient tout pro dormir dans la
même chambre
il y avait des pillages et des
cambriolages et quand les gens arrivent
et ne faisait pas dans le détail il
flingué tout le monde à nos chauffeurs
qui nous avait expliqué que s'il devait
crevé un pneu sur une zone la nuit il
n'allait pas s'arrêter il allait rouler
jusqu'à sa destination sans quoi il y
avait vraiment des risques pour sa peau
c'était vraiment une zone qui craignait
énormément et on sentait une tension qui
était comme un hyper palpable
je suis montre ton petit jouet là la
vraie montre le jir et vichy mais tu es
un homme dangereux
ah non pas du tout mais c'est ça ou je
le laisse à abuja j'adore je me rappelle
une journée était visité une cascade on
a pris la route et on est passé pas loin
d'une raffinerie de pétrole
une énorme raffinerie de mémoire c'était
total qui était sur place juste après la
raffinerie tu arrives dans un village
avec des cases des poules des gens qui
vivent comme on peut l'imaginer dans les
clichés africains à même le sol sur la
terre je me souviendrai toujours avoir
croisé le regard d'un gamin je me suis
dit [ __ ] six gamins s'il a une
mitraillette franchement une tire une
balle
il avait un regard de haine j'avais
l'impression de représenter le côlon qui
était venu à quelques mètres de chez lui
tu as vu une énorme raffinerie qui
prenait les ressources du pays en
quelque sorte les piliers faisait du
business avec et avait vraiment la
sensation que la population elle avait
absolument rien pour ces gens vivent
dans une extrême pauvreté et il voyait
débarquer toi leblanc qui arrive est là
pour aller voir les cascades au final
j'étais hyper mal à l'aise
tous les gens qu'on a pu côtoyer était
super sympa on était devenus potes avec
un musicien y avait un piano bar dans
l'hôtel le musicien était super sympa on
avait énormément sympathisé et après il
nous explique un peu nous file un petit
peu les tuyaux les astuces tous les
codes du pays et avait omis sûrement lié
à itunes not affect the movie hoquet
immobilier et seniors
un autre hôtel y avait plusieurs
restaurants il y avait aussi un bar se
barre l'éléphant de marque sheraton
abuja alors l'éléphante bar c'était
incroyable c'est un bar à cocktails
on venait pour boire des coups alors la
monnaie locale c'est le nerf à l'onera
si vous connaissais pas ça ressemble à
ça j'en ai gardé quelques-uns ça vaut
pas grand chose
j'ai dîné reims avons absolument rien
200 erreurs ça vaut pas grand chose non
plus 50 mais rares voilà ça c'est les
quelques souvenirs qui me reste du
nigeria vous vouliez un petit whisky
ça nous coûtait 4 150 nairas le problème
de l'éléphante bartik c'était aussi le
bar à prostituées de l'hôtel forcément
il ya une extrême pauvreté au nigeria
abuja beau avec la capitale ça reste
malgré tout une ville extrêmement
pauvres il y avait donc énormément de
prostitution au sein même de l'hôtel
directement dans l'éléphant de bach les
filles étaient là à les voir les mecs
elle avait absolument pas le droit de
monter elle même dans les chambres
mais il y avait énormément d'occidentaux
qui finissait la soirée avec des filles
je me rappelle avoir discuté on avait
aussi sympathisé avec la personne qui
faisait le ménage et qui nous disent hey
it's not god is not good
mais c'est clair c'est quand même
relativement bizarre tu te dis que c'est
le mec ils ont leurs femmes qui les
attend ils viennent pour une mission
alors pas tous à tous mes collègues avec
qui je bossais tous les collègues que
j'ai eu le plus proche pendant
l'opération il y en a aucun qui a fait
appel aux services des escortes de
l'éléphante barre par contre on avait
énormément d'étrangers beaucoup
d'anglais qui s'éclatait et qui
repartent avec des filles
il ya un souvenir qui va marquer aussi
c'est la circulation dans abuja
alors fatalement il ya des routes ya des
feux rouges et tout ce que vous voulez
il ya une signalisation comme en europe
comme en france comme partout dans le
monde d'ailleurs le problème c'est que
personne ne respecte rien tout le monde
passe à la convenance le klaxon c sport
national attention je parle je passe du
luth c'est incroyable pour les gens qui
sont là bas ils ont l'habitude mais toi
qui débarque là tu flippes c'est pire
que marseille 4 paris pert marseille tu
as vraiment un système d tu vois très
bien les mecs qui ont pété une bagnole
qui le répare avec des bouts de bric et
de broc
de toute façon ils ont rien donc comment
tu veux pouvoir acheter des pièces est
strictement impossible
alors les mecs ils sont extrêmement
bricoleur il te prenais une bagnole il
manque des pièces et agréable il
fabrique irait paris créé et ça repart
c'est incroyable
ces fascicules quête de 1504
baumet
jackson c'est le tambour here we go
au nigeria c'est vraiment une expérience
qui m'a fasciné mais qui m'a traumatisée
alors effectivement pendant un mois on
faisait pas grand chose
on attend des piscines hôtels
restaurants internet on allait au
cybercafé n'avait pas de wifi dans
l'hôtel donc on aller directement au
cybercafé
je me rappelle un jour sur le trajet on
a croisé une voiture de police alors moi
et mon appareil photo j'ai voulu les
prendre en photos ils m'ont capté en
train de les prendre en photos ils nous
ont arrêtés
j'ai planqué mon appareil vitesse grand
v et nous ont gardés au bord de la route
pendant 10 minutes donnez-nous
l'appareil qui vous aident quand vous
avez un appareil qu'est ce que vous
faites comme photo c'était hyper tendu
je me suis pas rendu compte sur le
moment mais quand on a pu repartir après
je me suis fait fumer comme jamais par
notre sauveur mesurait pas les risques
j'avais pas les codes du pays est
effectivement malgré tout c'est un pic
était très tendue et extrêmement
dangereux
beautiful day the time of my life as we
know it or not
le policeman le smap de caméras me
rappelle lorsque je suis rentré du
nigeria qu'à cette période là et pendant
un petit moment j'ai détesté les gens je
regardais les gens en france j'ai trouvé
tout ce plan qui avait pris conscience
de quelque chose là-bas d'une pauvreté
d'une misère d'un malheur je revoyais
sais je encore et quand je voyais les
gens en france et j'ai écouté se
plaindre pour relativement pas grand
chose alors après on se plaint toujours
pour notre quotidien on a le droit on va
pas sans lever droit mais quand on
rentre de ça quand je rentrais de cette
expérience du haut de mes 23 ans j'étais
écoeuré j'ai mis beaucoup de temps
réussir à revenir à réussir à me
réadapter et art et accepter les choses
il ya revivre normalement une des
premières choses qui n'a marqué au
nigeria c'est le climat c'était la
saison des pluies il y avait une
humidité tous tes vêtements et et moite
via voir un taux d'humidité l'ordre de
70% en enchaîner des phases d'orage des
phases de beau temps des phases d'orage
des phases de beau temps il veut notre
boîte qui bossait là bas mais il y avait
aussi une autre boîte qui préparait la
cérémonie d'ouverture
on avait discuté avec quelques personnes
de l'équipe et on avait pu devant le
chantier
c'était hallucinant mais complètement
hallucinant parce qu'en réalité en
france quand on monte des scènes en
france on a des structures métalliques
tout est extrêmement normes et c'est
hyper solide eu là bas ils prennent des
rectangles de bois qui cloue petit loup
qui pose et avec saïd phone 7 8% pour
une cérémonie d'ouverture pour quelque
chose d'énorme pour un événement
international en dehors de toutes les
normes qu'on avait connue c'est
extrêmement dangereux
c'était super bizarre là bas parce que
tous les mecs qui avaient un peu de
pouvoir
il faisait tous ça fait docteur donc tu
avais les docteurs de tout partout tu
savais pas docteur en quoi il était
docteur en rien mais c'est tout ça fait
docteur il y avait des gamins qui
bossait sur le chantier pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture des gamins qui
était calme relativement mal traités
parce qu'ils n'allaient pas assez vite
lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture la
femme qui coordonnait le lancement du
feu d'artifice pour en des mecs sur
place un des docteurs locaux à y aller
pas assez vite et elle avait pas envoyé
quand il fallait au final qu'est ce qui
s'est passé elle a pris une grande part
dans la tête parce que le mec penser
qu'elle n'avait pas fait son job comme
il fallait alors y avait probablement du
machisme derrière ça une femme qui avait
un poste important qui arrivait dans ce
pays là c'était très compliqué je pense
pour certaines personnes il y avait
énormément de machisme à mon arrivée au
nigeria tous mes collègues m'ont prévenu
on arrive dans ce pays on
dans permanence son passeport sur soi on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer il
faut toujours avoir son passeport
si besoin on peut repartir et au moins
dans nos papiers c'était hallucinant la
main à tous les carrefours il y avait
des gens qui faisaient de la mendicité
il vendait tout de la nourriture du
papier toilette des cartes pour
téléphoner il y avait de tout il y avait
vraiment un business pour tous et avec
toutes les petites baraques au coin de
rue les petits barbecue où les gens
faisait cuire de la bouffe les
brochettes locale je me suis pas tenté
mais ça avait l'air quand même sympa
ok go go go go go on avait fait un petit
resto local on est arrivés dans un
espèce de dos resto on a dit aux gens
qu'on voulait manger local nous ont
regardés en rigolant on a mangé
c'était sauce pas ici mais c'était
vraiment super ne soit rien
faux
arie vardi coudre et
rivoire pithiviers good au final j'ai
passé un mois au nigeria donc quasiment
28 jours à attendre mon matériel tous
les deux jours où vous lisez le matériel
arrive le matériel arrive le matériel
arrive il arrive absolument jamais
d'ailleurs une fois qu'il arrivait à
lagos qui est la plus grande ville
portuaire du nigeria qu'une ville cân
extrêmement dangereuse il a fallu qu un
des responsables de l'organisation
aïe à lagos avec une mallette de cash
pour à les dédouaner pour aller voir la
douaniers pour payer la douane ce que la
douane ne voulait pas dédouaner il
fallait toujours du cage du cash du cash
pour tous pas à mon niveau à leur niveau
à eux
oui ça c'est clair thaddée pas de catch
aérien à l'entrée de la zone où ont
bossé tous les matins tu avais des
centaines de personnes qui se réunissait
pour venir chercher du job
ils étaient là ils patientaient et avait
un gars chef d'equipe qui venait qu'ils
aient toi toi toi
vous venez vous bossez et il bossait
comme ça en dehors de tout ce qu'on
connaît nous les mecs viennent
il n'y a aucune règle de sécurité à des
containers qui sont surélevés dans le
ciel est à des mecs sur les containers
c'est extrêmement dangereux
on verrait ça chez nous onfray fermer
les boîtes et plus personne ne bosse
très il nigeria reste une expérience
incroyable c'était il ya treize ans j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya encore des moments
c'était comme hier je me revois encore
là bas si vraiment quelque chose qui m'a
énormément marqué à 23 ans je crois
qu'il une par mois qui restait là bas
bien que ce soit des moments heureux
mais difficile c'est des choses que
j'étais très heureux de partager et que
je referai sans aucune hésitation
d'ailleurs j'aurais adoré retrouver dans
ce pays mais vu la tension la situation
actuelle cela me semble extrêmement
compromis
[Musique]